[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts I love comedy ever since I was a
four-year-old boy and I got pulled out
of the smoking December 2nd
2019 and I'm a bigger comic than I've
ever been a better and I'm here now and
I can focus on just getting good and
there's nothing in like more [__]
cool than that the first ever inductee
to the brand new kill Tony Hall of Fame
ladies and gentlemen this is Michael
lair
[Applause]
[Music]
shut the [__] up extraordinary comedian
and kill Tony regular Michael layer
passed away on Tuesday after a six-year
battle with ALS Michael had been a
reoccurring guest on kill Tony ever
since his first appearance back in 2019
and is still the only member of the kill
Tony Hall of Fame which he was inducted
to just one month before his assisted
suicide took place last week
Tommy Michael we want you to be in they
can't Tony Hall of Fame I'm like what is
that
laughs
can I sleep there
will there be a credit check
because if so I will not pass
the entire comedy World seemed to be
shook by the news of Michael's death it
seemed like every comedian and their
brother was posting some sort of tribute
to Michael lair on Tuesday Joe Rogan
said quote the courageous man had to do
stand up while battling a debilitating
disease was insanely impressive and
though he struggled to get words out the
man would kill on stage he was a real
legend and I'm going to miss him very
much I love comedy ever since I was a
[__] little [__] four-year-old boy
and I got pulled out of the smoking
December 2nd
2019 and I'm a bigger comic than I've
ever been a better and I'm here now and
I can focus on just getting good and
there's nothing in like more [__]
cooler than that wow
wow wow wow wow wow that was beautiful
man that was so real yeah that's who you
are that was who you are that's
beautiful and that [__] joke about
how the South that's funny that's funny
as [__] dude that's real did you run out
of cocaine what happened and that's
another part of this wild story is
everything he's saying is true he went
down like a real he was on a real Bender
for a few weeks he got he was hanging
around some wild people and Austin is
[__] I guess everybody no one warned
me that everybody's on uppers here but
uh yeah we need to kill a mediocre
homeless person and transfer their
energy into your body yes in true
comedic fashion Michael Lair still had
one final joke prepared for all of us
after his death the same day as assisted
suicide was officially announced
Michael's Instagram account posted a
video of him and his dog captioned
Michael still gets all the [__]
followed by another post captioned I
told you I was sick so I was
just in Portland to a single for my
assistant suicide
obviously I didn't go through with it
in fact one third of people do not go
through winning but the worst part about
him was my daddy Uber driver on the way
home
good
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Paris Fashion Week ended yesterday with
some familiar faces taking the runway
Theo Von Andrew Schultz Andrew Santino
Stavros halcus Jeff Ross and Mateo Lane
all took the stage to tell some jokes
while rocking the newest fashion line
from kid super hit the middle and then
oh okay thank you guys can start and
move so you mean like you're in a tough
neighborhood
when asked about inspiration for the
comedy themed fashion show designer calm
dulane said you know me with kid super I
like to do non-conventional fashion
shows so the idea is like it's a Comedy
Central roast and I want it to go all in
on fashion but I want to be
tongue-in-cheek not super mean
[Music]
[Applause]
this show looks to have been a huge
success and featured some pretty big
names in comedy so later this week we're
going to upload a video with some more
details around the event and highlight
some of the funniest moments on stage
from these comedians with that being
said please make sure to turn post
notifications for this channel on right
now otherwise you're a huge [__] guest
spots from last week your mom's house
had on Tom segura's mom Charo two bears
1K was Bert and Louis CK kill Tony
tonight is Ian Edwards Andrew Santino
Sarah weinshank and Kim Condon flagrant
had on Andrew Santino Dan Soder was the
guest on take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman and whiskey Ginger had on the
New York boys Sal vulcano Chris estefano
and Joe DeRosa the studio stinks
from the people downstairs at a
chandelier store which isn't a real
store by the way obviously how many
[__] shambles who's buying
chandeliers zero people yeah no you have
though I shouldn't I shouldn't even I
have three chandeliers in my house right
now describe describe them sure in the
entryway what's called a before yeah
yeah
all right a kind of a art deco bulb
situation beautiful uh in the in the
bedroom I have a beautiful Crystal uh
kind of glass situation and then over in
the dining room I have a much more
modern uh circular light situation wow
yeah very nice now what's your lighting
situation in your place Joe no
chandeliers
LED strips Joe lives over a dumpling
shops below you yeah I'm not allowed to
have anything that I would be able to
hang myself from
let me jump in here Joe's actually he's
got a a his apartment's small but
honestly you have one of the tidiest
like you have the way you have your
apartment set up you have so much stuff
and it's organized so well that it's
it's almost like a little like when you
walk into his apartment you're like wow
this guy's got his [__] together I like
how you talk about me like I'm a man
that was released from some sort of
program that's able to Now function on
his own were you were you a little bit
yeah I mean uh yes I'm the only one of
the three of us that does not have a
house do you clean look at his curl it
looks like a pigtail
tail of a pig this past weekend with
Thea Von had on Kyle from nelk The Joe
Rogan Experience also had on Louis CK
the blocks podcast with Neil Brennan
also had on Andrew Santino David Cross
was on are you garbage and TJ Miller was
on tigerbelly as far as brand new comedy
specials either coming out soon or have
come out very recently Nathaniel
McIntosh had a YouTube special called
money never wakes that's a 45 minutes
you can find it on YouTube came out four
days ago very funny I definitely
recommend go checking that out Nate
bargatzi News special hello world comes
to Amazon Prime on January 31st that's
very exciting huge expectations for Nate
there that's got to be funny I mean he
never misses and this weekend Louis CK
will be live streaming from the middle
of Madison Square Garden at 7 30 p.m
Eastern tickets are on sale right now on
Louie's website for just 25 bucks each
and once it's gone it's gone this is not
a special it's just a live streamed
comedy event that does it for this
episode of the joke worlds comedy update
as always thank you so much for watching
this video I think this was episode
number 35 so that's pretty sweet thank
you so much for watching and we'll be
back again next Monday with some more
comedy news but in the meantime we got
some other great content coming up on
this page I try not to laugh with a
comedian I'm going to keep secret but I
think you guys are really gonna [__]
like it so make sure those post
notifications are on and Diving deeper
into the Paris fashion week with these
comedians guys like Theo Von Andrew
Schultz Andrew Santino Jeff Ross Mateo
Lane Stavros it's a packed packed show
that they had there we're gonna dive way
deeper into it show some of their best
moments on stage so make sure your post
notifications are on for that video or
else you're just gonna have to keep your
eyes peeled you're gonna have to peel
those eyes right out of your head and
don't want you to do that just turn on
those notifications baby all right I'll
see you next Monday sorry for calling
you baby
[Music]